hello everyone welcome to my channel
in this video we'll talk about adaptive
immunity so this video would include
these following points
we'll talk about the cellular players of
the adaptive immune system
we'll talk about the time and place of
adaptive immune response
phases of the adaptive immune response
and
how adaptive and the inner immune
response is
breached by several molecular players so
this is what we are going to learn at
the end of this video
so stay tuned till the end of this video
now let us look at
first the players of the adaptive immune
system
they are simply the major players are t
cell
and the b cell which are developed from
the lymphoid progenitors
present in the bone marrow now in my
earlier video i have already talked
about the inner immune system components
which has
eosinophil basophil neutrophil nk cells
mast cells etc
and also macrophages and dendritic cell
now the important part about the
macrophages and the dendritic cell
is they can be a connection between
these two
immune responses in it and adaptive
now the dendritic cell takes special
part connecting in connecting these two
systems
in this video we can appreciate that so
let's look at the overall framework of
adaptive immune system
how does it work so it's kind of like a
second line
of mechanism for
attacking the pathogens so let's say
these pathogens have invaded our body
they could be viruses they could be
bacteria
so first of all when they enter in order
of hours to in order of one day
the dendritic cell or macrophages as
they are phagocytotic
they would act upon them and try to
engulf those
pathogens so the immediate immune
response if we briefly described
they would recognize the pathogen they
would engulf the pathogen
and they would inform the adaptive
immune system
about these pathogen invasion so they
provide the
adaptive immune system these kind of
intel about the pathogens
now after they recognize the pathogen
and try to
try their best to neutralize the
pathogen they
some of these innate immune system
components such as the dendritic cell
actually establish connection between
adaptive and inner immunity
and they migrate towards the uh
lymph node where the adaptive immune
components reside and they
inform them about the in infection
history
so uh active connection between adaptive
and innate immune system
is very important for a successful
immune response to happen
so let us look at a case study and try
to understand with a real example let's
say we are
pricking our hand with a nail and
accidentally this is a rusty nail which
had a lot of bacteria along with it
so the bacteria has entered our body now
obviously
the macrophages the dendritic cell which
are just beneath the skin
would quickly try to engulf those
pathogens
now first of all before engulfing they
would recognize them then they would
engulf them
so let's look at a dendritic cell to
understand this process so the dendritic
cell would engulf the pathogen
then this pathogen would be fusing
with a lysosome and the endolysosome
would be formed where the pathogen would
be degraded
ultimately the degraded peptides derived
from this pathogen would be displayed on
class 2 mhc molecule
such that these can be presented to the
t cells
or the adaptive immune components such
that they know about
the history of invasion so
the macrophages and dendritic cell would
secrete cytokines
and that would attract other cells in a
near vicinity
to come closer and fight with them right
as if they are calling for
backup some of these dendritic cells
would be
motile and they would migrate towards
the lymph node
and very important events of the
adaptive immune system
is taking part place in the lymph node
so
in the lymph node the immature b cell
which is naive b cell which has all the
capability
of recognizing the pathogen or producing
antibodies would eventually be activated
so
these in it so these image immune system
components
activates the adaptive immune components
so let us look at this process in bit
more details by zooming into
a component inside the lymph node so
here we zoom into the lymph node
and we can see the germinal center or
the
follicles for the b cell area and
paracortex where t cell resides
now what happens is
when the b cells are activated they
proliferate rapidly
increasing their number some of them
could be
quickly differentiated into short-lived
plasma cells
and some of them can be really
differentiated to a long-leaf plasma
cell we'll come to that
and everything is dependent upon what
type of antigen
b cell is encountering now b cell
activation could be via t
cell and those are known as uh t cell
dependent antigens
so in this case t cell and b cell
interaction leads to very strong diesel
activation
but b cell don't really need really
require t cell for its activation
b cell can be activated in an individual
format
so b cell can be activated by repetitive
antigens as shown here
or by directly via tone like receptor or
let's say by directly recognizing a
portion of the
pathogen but these are relatively weak
degree of
activation for the b cells no matter
what
way they are activated eventually
they would start the cell cycle process
and they would proliferate in number
they would increase in number
so obviously let us assume that our t
helper cell is activating a
b cell and these t
helper cell is actually a follicular t
cell in a different video we'll talk
about follicular t cell in a lot more
details
but let's say this follicular t cell has
activated this b cell so immediately
this b
cell can generate short-lived plasma
cells and secrete
the specific membrane-bound ige sorry
the secretory igm
into the bloodstream such that uh the
effector molecules are already in the
bloodstream
that's a relatively quick response but
for a long term one the b cell can be
proliferating in the
follicles and then it can differentiate
into
antibody secreting plasma cells which is
long lived
and these plasma cells would be residing
for several weeks to months
so let us look at this process in a bit
more details to understand the kinetics
of it
so in the b cell follicle
the b cells which are activated are now
proliferating
the b cells which has very high affinity
of receptors
or very high affinity of antibodies they
would
be surviving otherwise which have very
low affinity antibodies they would be
dead by apoptosis now the low affinity
interactions can be um modulated or
there is a cell
known as follicular dendritic cell which
can rectify these kind of
low affinity interaction and try to
rescue this
if they are rescued then it would if the
low affinity problem is solved then they
are rescued
and they are differentiated to plasma
cell otherwise they are dead
so few important events of adaptive
immune response
takes place in this b-cell follicle via
the i mean or the terminal center
those are somatic hypermutation which
are
mutations that can lead to
increase or decrease in affinity of the
b
cell membrane bound antibody now
obviously the high affinity
antibodies would be selected the b cells
which are having high affinity antibody
would be selected and the low affinity
one would be
deleted or by apoptosis so the high
affinity ones would be differentiated
eventually to the plasma cells and this
process is known as somatic
hypermutation
and about somatic hypermutation i have a
different video so you can click on the
i button to watch that
now these plasma cells
had already done a process which is
known as class switching that means
when it was a b cell it was only able to
generate membrane bound igm
or igd now with the cluster switching
process they can also secrete igg
or other kind of isotypes
so these are the key events that are
happening in
b cell follicle in the lymph node and
this is a very
crucial step in the adaptive immune
response i'll tell you why
so in order to understand that let us
look at the overall time
course of the adaptive immune response
let us go by phase by phase
so first phase is the activation of the
adaptive immune components such as the t
cells and the b cells so t cells can be
activated by the antigen presenting
cells and the b cells can be activated
by the t cells or individually no matter
what
b cell and t cell would eventually
proliferate so there is a recognition
phase
and there is a clonal expansion phase
followed by plural expansion phase there
would be a activatory phase where the t
cells are getting activated and also the
b cells are getting activated and
differentiated into plasma cells
now they would start the effector
response
either the humeral immune response or
the cell-mediated immune response that
would really fight the pathogen so
effective response is a very important
stage in these
adaptive immune response but after a
while when the issue is resolved and the
pathogens are dead then these elevated
level of antibody or elevated level of
these activated t cells might be harmful
so they eventually die
right so they are eventually they
eventually die most of them
die so there is a declining phase so
their number would rapidly decline
but some of them do not die and they
form the memory cells so
memory cells are generated in this way
if you want to learn more about the
memory cells
there are quite a lot of hypothesis and
controversies about memory
cell generation so you can click the
link in the i button to learn more about
the memory cells
so getting back to the temporal kinetics
of the immune response
so let us talk about the antibody
mediated immune response which is
also under adaptive immune response and
try to understand the kinetics
so this is how the antibody response
look like
so the red one is igm level and the
yellow one is actually igg level and the
white arrow
denotes the time course of the pathogen
exposure
so when the pathogen is exposed after 10
days
it turns out that igm antibodies would
be produced
and after 20 days approximately igg
antibodies would be produced so these
time points are approximate so it takes
10 to 14 days to produce igm secretory
igm firstly
now there is a lag right
from the day of exposure to the
antibody in the circulation there is a
lag and this lag
is due to recognition then
presentation to the adaptive component
and thereby only the
adaptive component can uh make the
antibodies so this whole process is a
lengthy process so it takes time
but in case of a secondary immune
response this
lag is relatively low within a course of
three days
the igm can be produced and within a
course of 10 days
the igg can be produced so the second
time
when the same pathogen is invading our
body the immune response is faster and
higher in magnitude
this is because the memory b cells after
primary infection most of the cells die
but some of them leave which becomes the
memory b cell
broadly speaking this memory b cell have
a memory of the pathogen that had
invaded the particular memory which is
encoded in the
molecular level in the second time
invasion they just need to recall that
what type of antigen they had
encountered in past and they can quickly
differentiate into antibody secreting
plasma cells
and secrete the antibody necessary to
neutralize that pathogen
so that is why in the secondary immune
response the lag is so
short the key aspect of the secondary
immune response is generation of the
memory cell that's a key response
so just to summarize this video we
learned
the cells that are involved in adaptive
immune response
the overview of the adaptive immune
system the phases of adaptive immune
response
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you guys thanks for
listening